boy where's my camera that's and that's
why I'm in a restaurant in Vegas right
your sister runs right Joe yeah just
stop yeah not a time for you to I'm just
trying to get you a Rolex but what am i
what are you doing it's a fake laughing
dude you're doing a high I'm successful
and so is he not so much hey what the
[ __ ] cha just saying this is my place
sure and you're showing up a news clip
wearing my sweatshirt you're trying to
promote your brand with my just workout
that's a [ __ ] news that's cashmere
sweater yes that's a [ __ ] Russell
Athletic Center from dick take it back -
I'm not taking it back right now get it
you can't even fix that in the color
code what are you trying to adjust the
color [ __ ] gray [ __ ] you a great what's
not great tix brings out my eyes you
don't have a success roasting Oh what
you're [ __ ] a restaurant so I can not
go dropped it's a radius right oh yeah
that's amazing your sister what do I
serve you to be that Philippine no I
said Japanese laser believes no no not
believe dude he was laser out there was
brought there worked on nine different
UFOs we have video he worked on nine
different nine of them at area 51 dude
if you discredit laser i'ma [ __ ] you up
I just feel like once feel okay I just
feel like I just want to say one thing
is it possible that he is a liar
why would he eat why would why the [ __ ]
do you believe a guy that cleans his
nails with a [ __ ] knife and scribe
several because I was trying I mean
reals trying to one this guy actually
worked with UFOs on a very secured area
51 guys where's the EV granny did you
not educate yourself before you dude
there are aliens are real aliens are
real I would bet my bottom dollar made
contact with us
they sure have sorry Han on earth yeah
have we have there's one where
we have nine of them nine why don't you
know hey dude bright won't you grab your
phone real quick your iPhone I mean you
don't believe in a you sound like this
guy who put a bomb in the [ __ ] and I
sound like an educated human being a
take it easy dude you don't believe in
eight are you have your hat off and why
are you pointing it at me just relax
supreme expensive okay dude you don't
believe in aliens I don't know about
aliens but I don't know that we have
nine spaceships I would love that
don't you think we are in here he said
he worked on him what did he do on and
they scooped them up I'm asking I'm
asking questions drive me crazy bro I
don't know can I tell you a story real
quick yes he's just real quick please
so chris d'elia is on the road now right
he's opening for me yeah we get to this
one town every city that we go to were
the funniest guys there yeah anywhere we
go to a coffee bean we go to a Panera
Bread were the plenteous popular people
to walk in we get to this town
funny Posse it's it's called I think
it's called Dayton Ohio I think I'm
pretty sure you behind a name we got a
date and all of us so we're not the
funny people everywhere we go the Panera
we go to a [ __ ] some restaurant and
everyone's odd everything everything is
a lot so Chris and I go to the room and
we start laughing and we're like dude
you know what this town is the
government that built this town because
this is where they breed aliens and then
they breed them here and then they ship
them out into the regular world so how
do they work here like they work with
them here to deal with like people that
are transient coming through and dealing
with regular humans right we were laughs
and we're dying so hard at this theory
right so the guy that comes and picks us
up for the for the show he's driving us
to the to the to the show and and then
Chris is sitting in the front seat I'm
sitting in the back and I go hey my man
um are there any aliens or
spaceship set that uh fly around here
and we just we giggle to ourselves Chris
and I are laughing to ourselves right
and the guy goes yeah uh roswall crashes
here the the spaceship from Roswell
Roswell right Roswell Roswell the
Roswell spaceship is here and it's in
hangar let's check this out he goes chin
you you and you're on the alien train as
well I've always kind of believed it
listen listen this kind of believed it
listen the best part of the story he
goes the Roswell crash is here it's in
hangar like 52 you can look at hangar 18
hangar 18 I swear to God
Kris and I we were laughing all day all
day we were laughing when this guy said
this Kris night we look [ __ ] ghost
face we look at each other like what
though lot of images Brian you don't
think it's inbred leadership this is a
real hater in Dayton Ohio that looks
like a hangar now listen let's loosen no
we were joking around about this holes
million [ __ ] yeah well that guy said
that to us it freaked us the [ __ ] out
because that's literally how that town
felt it felt like they were like
breathing up human
I'm just saying it it will show he said
there might be a roof oh alright well
that's my story then pulled out on me
that was one of the weirdest weirdest
[ __ ] things I've ever experienced
we're at [ __ ] big-ass clock like conk
what happened I froze like this what
happened okay oh that's all I did
and then my friend was like this years
have no idea what did my friend was
literally looking at the gun like that
and he goes are we cool
oh absolutely definitely cool
everybody's cool everybody's cool man
what he's just trying to rob you guys uh
it was a car situation that we were in
and it was just mouthing off and then he
pulled out the gun I was like god it's
crazy how powerful guns are it yo it was
like my here's what I was mostly scared
about how about if we hit a bump or a
car the Marvin potion you're Marvin and
Paul Feig yeah literally well yeah
that's what I was thinking I was
literally thinking that cuz I was like
yo to move that gun I know like just
move it up like face it towards were
that's what I was saying myself but he
had it like he had like that and I'm
just like god they're so scared got guns
in my house now and yet for him to see
well yeah they change it to Stiller yes
I can't I don't perform in restaurants
anymore well no you you just did that
huh oh you
did that I know about it years ago those
eyes that was last thing I saw you doing
a promo on Instagram hey get fish and
chips and see me live like the fish come
see all you can eat fish and chips and
comedy Thursdays with Bryan Callen three
tickets no buy one get one free
come see the kid I don't like I don't
like any of this I don't like where this
look line and sinker hook line and
sinker comedy come see the kid live
nothing more depressed buy one till you
get 7 free just come please
all-you-can-eat tartar sauce like any
went like that all-you-can-eat tartar
sauce tartar come see the other half of
fighter in the kid the kid the one
that's not as attractive why are you why
Oman wait where's my camera got me on
this right you you'll fight right now
yes shingles - I have shingles stammers
why did you let me touch her in the I'll
rub why would you let me touch right
here wasn't my pustules on you I'll beat
you up and that'll give you shingles so
don't touch you and be it the whole kid
you can beat me up just don't touch I'm
a good-looking guy I didn't think about
you ever see Brad Pitt like what was
that movie where that he becomes old
dude like Benjamin Benjamin viroid he
was good-looking and then he got a lot
of you like mmm yeah like I can see like
like you were you probably cute when
you're a kid and now say like let's just
get into it man yeah Brian's late empty
one sends me it takes it goes bro lost
track of time
be there soon who loses track of time
I don't even know what that is by the
way I don't even know what losing track
of time is but here's the problem we've
been doing the show for six years yeah
it's the same time every Wednesday yeah
if it but it's so you know it's not like
oh it's a crazy Thursday and yeah except
I suppose one have a guess it was just
me I'm used to it yeah I do die used to
have inner demons mmm think about
killing Brian when he'd be late
something I probably quit the show four
to five times because he's late all the
time yeah and they stopped being late he
hasn't been late in a while yeah it used
to be a real problem
yeah I'm just like a chalking up it's
Brian yeah but you can kind of see that
with Brian's progression in life he lost
track it's it's always been losing
trackers yeah and now it's really
hitting them and now it's like hey i'ma
do a special it's like I think you lost
track of time
yeah that should have been done 15 years
ago but yeah hey good job well boom oh I
sold out a Singapore how the [ __ ] did
that happen well no I'm just saying and
you can too yeah for sure
yeah for sure yeah 100% yeah like that
like you should always look at somebody
and not hate on them but be inspired by
them like yo that dude sold out an arena
I can sell an arena 100% 100% always use
that as inspiration let let the haters
hate because that's only gonna feed your
fire yeah anyone that hates it's just
gonna be only part the only person that
gets affected by shouting out hatred or
or or throwing hate year away that
they're the only ones that suffer
because they're using all their energy
to promote your product yeah that's how
you gotta look at [ __ ] don't ever think
of like yo this dude's hating on me
that's gonna affect my business know
what it's gonna help your business well
I realize you're still that guy is
giving other people that guy is using
his platform
to give them a chance to figure out
whether or not they hate you and they
got our own assumptions that's all he's
doing
he's going hey guys I hate that guy what
are your thoughts yeah probably about
80% of your bike I kind of like them so
thanks for telling me
yeah thanks and then the other 20% is
like y'all with you and those [ __ ]
you don't want anyway Ameri asked you I
went I went hey ham how do you deal with
hate and you just sent me a picture of a
race horse with blinders yeah
I did picture my book did you really oh
yeah cuz it's real I always ask people
way more success to me like how do you
deal with like haters and the activity
he's he didn't say anything he's put
seven picture oh I can race or the horse
with Akkad a race horse and the horse is
like [ __ ] wit's line ders that
[ __ ] only has one thing in front
of them the [ __ ] prize yeah in front
of them yep and all your haters are
though are the people sitting in the
stands yeah betting against you yep I
all my teeth have been ripped out of my
mouth I was one of those hot you I
thought you had a dip in no I've got a
dip and I was like that's cool oh man
what happened I had two veneers see that
yeah so I have veneers well all of our
veneers but I fell on a rock when I was
a kid and that's why I got the veneers
and then uh the the the stud that was in
here F collapsed two days ago and they
had to rip it out of my mouth and read
yeah so because that is stud in there
since I was like like 13 when I fell on
the rock and it's you know the material
they were using back then was like steel
or something not healthy and it
collapsed so all this has been ripped
out and they put new ones every days ago
they put new my teeth in two days just
nice yeah they put new ones in yeah
there's these are all temps I get my new
ones in two week that's it's gonna hurt
when they put that in yeah there's
anything worse than mouth pain oh
nothing
how about like tooth problem thank God
for modern day dental oh my god what did
we do I know what we did we lost our
teeth I was at when I was in Tempe
Arizona
this guy had that's exactly what
happened that's exactly what just ripped
it out it's not whose teeth are the
third ones in yeah who is that that is
[ __ ] rad yeah [ __ ]
what is so you know what that is that's
when they file the Tia combin ears yes
oh you're [ __ ] yeah they filed all of
mine like that yeah it's all not but now
I'm missing teeth I'm not doing what do
you think this was gonna get veneers
amount that hurt you think this guy
right here ever says um what is it that
you don't like about me do you think he
ever you
something I said I don't get it I don't
think it doesn't go like this beauty
skin d yeah I'm a good time I'm a nice
gamma good guys right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]